hey guys how's it goin so this is a
really special video and I am really
excited to make this because I'm giving
away my old iPhone 5s Genta done now
I've been talking about this for the
past couple of weeks telling you guys
that I was going to auction off my phone
for charity I wasn't even talking about
it before I even got the new iPhone what
I'm so excited about is how this all
came to be so me my sister and my friend
and JB waited over 55 hours for the new
phone outside of the Apple store and on
the first day we met this guy Cody who
we had talked to for about I don't know
10 hours the first day of our campout
for the iPhone 6
I met Cody here I mentioned that I was
going to be auctioning off for charity
but I hadn't chosen my charity and me
and Cody are here or is it Cody and I
are at the Apple store right now we're
camping out for the new iPhone look at
that what do you think of our tent so
Cody got really excited because he
actually had a charity that we could
donate to it's called the Napa Center
Kids Foundation all of this was timed
perfectly
we had our charity we met Cody who was
such an amazing inspiring person not
only did we get our new phones Cody got
his new phone and now I have this phone
that I'm able to auction off for the
Napa Center Kids Foundation for more
information about Cody about the
foundation and how to bid on this iPhone
plus a bunch of other goodies which I'm
going to tell you about the link is in
the description I'm so excited now not
only you're going to be getting a phone
I will also record you a personal video
which I will put on the phone I can also
email it to you because you're probably
gonna want to format this phone and set
it up as a new one I'll give you my
favorite c3po iPhone case which is over
there is my favorite so I hope that you
will enjoy it as well I will also
include not one but two iJustine so so
happy hoodies I can also sign any of
this stuff unless you don't want me to
sign it totally fine we'll also have a
FaceTime call which you can call me from
this phone or your computer or however
you FaceTime this whole bag of eBay
goodies which includes $300 an ebay gift
card so basically it's free money and
inside of this bag
I actually don't even know what's in
here yet eBay sent it to me for you guys
eBay colored tissue paper it's all
packed so nicely an eBay Journal
something secret a scarf oh yeah are we
ready for winner a little jacket here's
the gift cards I think this is a mug
eBay headphones a little sippy cup all
of this could be yours and probably more
I'll find some other things that I have
around my room like maybe some Lego
stuff and I'll just put it in the box
for you you're wondering about the
condition of my iPhone 5s it is gold is
actually a pretty new phone I had two
replacements in the past couple of
months the first one was damaged in
Iceland in the Blue Lagoon
the second was shattered from this
incident in New York or tween and this
scarf is so much cooler than a surgical
mask
so this phone I just got not even a week
ago well guess what
someone's got to make a trip to the
Genius Bar let's take it again so thanks
to you guys for watching and bidding and
thanks to eBay for making all of this
happen because I am just so excited that
not only are you guys going to get all
of these crazy fun goodies you're also
gonna be making a difference in someone
else's life in Cody's life to the Napa
Center to my life um I I just love you
guys you're so awesome and I'm so
excited to see who gets all the goodies
so yeah I'll see you later
thanks again bye